at this altitude I can run flat out
before my hands this episode is brought
to you by convertkit my go-to email
service provider I use them for
everything if you've ever wondered how
professional bloggers podcasters
youtubers and so on can build a platform
they control and get the word out about
their best content email is still the
answer people think it's all social
social social but one algorithm change
and oops bait and switch now you only
reach 10% of your audience that is why
I've doubled and tripled down on email
after reviewing many different email
service providers I ended up selecting
convertkit for email like 500 Friday
which goes out to about a million people
now because convertkit delivers on what
matters most to me at least easy to use
systems split testing and resending
technology both very very important high
rates of deliverability and great hands
on customer service so whether you run a
business or simply have say a serious
blog convertkit has integrations with
more than 70 different services just
about anything you might need including
hosting sites like WordPress e-commerce
platforms like Shopify lead capture
technology like bounce exchange or sumo
and many more they also offer a visual
automation builder that makes it really
easy to deliver the right content to the
right people in your audience just when
they want it if you want a segment in
different ways which a lot of people do
convert kit offers plans that adjust to
the size of your business so it's a good
option whether you have a thousand
people or 1 million on your list and
certainly I am planning on growing and
growing and growing and I don't like
switching email service providers so I
thought very carefully about this before
I selected them so check it out
take a look at convertkit dot-com a
forward slash Tim that's convert Co nver
tki t.com forward slash Tim and you can
get your first month for free to kick
the tires test it out that way you can
give it a shot make sure that it works
for you your business and
of that goodness if you're like me I
hope you'll find that they get the job
done that's certainly been my experience
so check it out again
that's convertkit comm forward slash Tim
for a free month of email services this
episode is brought to you by
wordpress.com
I love WordPress I have used it for so
many years it's my go-to platform for
blogging and creating websites I use
wordpress.com for everything every day
my site Tim not blog is built on it the
websites for my books including tools of
titans tribe of mentors it's all on
wordpress.com and the founder matt
mullenweg
when my close friends has appeared on
this show many times
just search matt mullenweg tequila
Ferriss for quite an exciting time
whether you're looking to create a
personal blog a business site or both
you can make a really big impact right
out of the box when you build on
wordpress.com and you'll be in good
company it's used by the New Yorker
jay-z Beyonce 5:38 TechCrunch Ted CNN
and time just to name a handful and one
of my friends at Google she'll remain
nameless has told me that wordpress.com
offers the quote best out-of-the-box SEO
imaginable end quote and it's one of the
many reasons that nearly 30 percent of
the Internet is run on WordPress you do
not need experience or to hire someone
that's perhaps the best part
wordpress.com guides you through the
entire experience they have hundreds of
designs and templates that you can use
and it's easy to get started there's no
need to worry about security upgrades
hosting any of that therefore 24/7
support and they're very very responsive
if you have questions they get right
back to you and this allows you to
create the highest quality with the
least amount of headache and friction so
if you're building a website period when
my friends come to me and ask what I use
what I recommend they use the answer is
wordpress.com so check it out if you
want to get started today learn more
with a 15% discount off any new plan go
to wordpress.com forward slash Tim to
create your website and find the plan
that's right for you so learn more take
a look word
dot-com 4/10 for 15% off a brand new
website check it out
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show and my brand new
podcasts tribe of mentors because this
guest is suitable for both Mike maples
he's one of my favorite people one of my
oldest mentors not in biological age but
he goes back probably 15-20 years
teaching me and he is the man who
effectively taught me how to invest and
the audio you're gonna hear was recorded
in front of a sold-out audience at the
Castro theatre in San Francisco it was a
blast thank you everyone for coming out
and it takes us a few minutes to warm up
and then we get into not only investing
but also his life philosophies parenting
he is such a splendid human being and
has a very very wide set of skills so I
hope you enjoy this conversation with
Mike maples thank you so much for coming
everybody this is gonna be great
and I'll read some suggested
introductory remarks first thank you all
for coming tonight welcome to tonight's
program with inform at the Commonwealth
Club and what I'm not gonna do is sit
here and regurgitate stuff that is
already in the book that you just bought
because that's very boring so what I
thought I would do instead is invite one
of my friends who is in this book to
join me on stage and to dig into some of
the old stories the stuff you guys
haven't heard and to really just banter
because he is one of my favorite people
so who is this favorite person Kevin
Rose is one of my favorite people but he
has a brand new human being to take care
of so he is not here to booze it up with
Ferriss I'm very sad to say Mike maples
jr. you can find him on Twitter at M -
jr. floodgate com Mike maples jr. is a
partner at floodgate a venture capital
firm that specializes in micro cap
investments in startups he's also the
person responsible for introducing me to
tech investing
and we go way way back he has been on
the Forbes Midas list since 2010 and
named one of Fortune Magazine's eight
rising stars before becoming a full-time
investor this is very important
Mike was an operator he was involved as
a founder and operating executive it
back to back startup IPOs including
tivoli systems its acquired by IBM
motive IPO motive acquired by
alcatel-lucent some of Mike's
investments include Twitter twitch.tv ng
moko Weebly Chegg bizarre voice
Spiceworks okhta demand force and many
many many others please help me welcome
to stage Mike maples
yeah yeah I I thought we were just
having a little chat and like a
bookstore something I guess you tend to
draw a crowd I keep forgetting that yeah
so I was trying to put us connecting on
a timeline and I think we've had a
number of of interactions beginning it
had to be back pre mm yeah I think and I
think that when we first started
catching up it was um right before you
had done the 4-hour workweek and you
were so Tim but Tim wasn't sure what to
call this but my is just anything goes
anything goes I may regret a lot but
yeah so Tim and you know I'm a little
bit less over my skis sometimes in Tim
is well it depends on the area but
whatever so but so Tim was deciding
whether to call the book the 4-hour
workweek or drug dealing for fun and
profit and and I was like Tim why do you
want to write a book about being a
druggie you know this is just terrible
idea you know you'd be just a terrible
influence just just a bad idea and Tim
was like well you know you really want
to get people you know sort of to
provoke to point a departure right to to
get access to the ideas and so we did
this thing I think we called it ghetto
testing where we said hey look let's not
argue
let's not in your opinion versus mine
let's just test the two titles and just
say hey by the 4-hour workweek hey by
drug dealing for fun and profit and you
know neither book exists yet so people
would click on it they get a 404 error
but we could we could understand like
what got the better response yet so now
it was no longer your opinion versus
mine it was just like what do people
respond to but so so yeah we did this
that's my record yes no we had testing
but it goes even further back so you had
appeared I was more of a spectator in a
class that I took in college oh and you
were so I take under pressure back when
I had more hair on my head and Mike came
to talk about thunderlizards yes which
we'll talk about in a moment and that
was part
of what piqued my interest in Silicon
Valley the bay area the excitement
certainly of the time 99 who granted
this an exciting time to be running
towards the precipice also but got me
out here and then our conversations
around the time that the 4-hour workweek
came out involved to my recollection
many things but we would sit at and I
might be getting this wrong but hobee's
hobee's yeah in town and country italic
which unfortunately no longer with us
it's a Vuitton at raster Darrow but on
and we used to just eat omelets
and and talk about marketing and PR but
also about the deals that you were
becoming involved with yeah and the the
testing for people who don't know was
very simple I mean we had a number of
different titles and used Google AdWords
which was I mean it was the Golden Age
of Google AdWords you could just shoot
fish in a barrel it was so inexpensive
and so he took the the headlines of
prospective headlines as the as the
actual ad headlines and then the
prospective subtitles as the ad text and
then had all these unique URLs that like
you said went nowhere because all we
really cared about was the click-through
rate what I also did if we want to talk
about businesses going out of business
or a lot of them but point do is I went
to Palo Alto University have to the
borders that existed at the time and to
test covers I had mock-ups that I
printed out and I would wrap a book that
was roughly the same size I thought mine
would be put it up during what I
perceived to be rush hour at borders not
sure how I figured that out and I would
stand there like a bouncer keeping track
of fire code like click click watching
the number people who picked it up like
every 15 minutes so I could try to look
at the visual appeal of different covers
now it's a lot easier you don't have to
quite do that skill is why oh yeah I
should maybe I need some booze up here
we'll get to that but what I wanted to
do so can I just interject one other
thing about these boom she'd interject
oh so many other things so I went to
Kepler's book store and printers ink I
guess right because they're they're like
well known as bellwether bookstores and
and I was like I'm gonna I went and
bought $1,000 worth of his book for our
work week at both bookstores
and we didn't really know at the time
but bellwether bookstores kind of
trigger supply chains and so it's a
little bit like before the App Store
happened right because the iPhone wasn't
out yet and so so like I'd go into these
bookstores I'd be like how many copies
do you have in the bookstore I want to
buy them all because this book is gonna
be hot and I'm doing this off-site and I
need every copy you've got because I
doubt you have enough copies for all
people and this organization I've run
and so which was just me at the time but
but like what it turned out it was true
write it like it becomes oh wow Kepler's
book store printers ink
they're selling out like crazy afore I
work week and that it was a hot heat
seeker on the New York Times and then
more people read it it becomes up with
it obviously was a good book that helped
but uh but it was like just looking back
on it how how crazy that was because
either like maybe you thought it was
gonna be this huge breakout bestseller
but I remember I was just like hey I'll
read these drafts and blows however I
can and like I hope it works out but
yeah whatever right it was I think you
offered one of the very first blurbs in
the first edition of four hour work week
after don't read additional copies ago
okay yeah I got you a quote one but what
when we're talking about this alchemy
for instance Kepler's let's just say so
unbeknownst to me there certain stores
that trigger certain other things and
there's this Lex a black magic but
there's this these tipping points so now
people look at what you've accomplished
and the investments you've made and the
- lists and everything and it's oh my
god Mike maples and sort of in in
quotation marks but my understanding is
that you had a tough time like getting
hired as a venture capitalist when you
first got here yeah talk a little bit
about that you know it's like in
coachbuilt camp how many people have
heard of coach Bill Campbell before a
fair number and for those of you haven't
I'll just give the quick version bill
was an early executive at Apple and then
he ran a company called klaris and then
go which flamed out and then he was CEO
of Intuit but probably more
significantly became kind of the most
famous coaches
Elkin Valley he'd been a football coach
before he's a business guy and so he was
on the board of Google and Apple and
actually I got a chance to work with him
and Twitter and in demand force works
for two companies he got involved with
that we invested in and Bill's favorite
song was you can't always get what you
want by the Rolling Stones and it always
struck me that and we won't do too much
of the book but that that sometimes you
the stuff you're not getting right now
that you think you want wasn't the thing
you really wanted and so I couldn't get
any venture firms to hire me coming to
Silicon Valley it's just this random guy
who'd moved to Silicon Valley from
Austin Texas never done an angel
investment in my life and you know Kevin
Rose one of your favorite guys one of my
favorites too the first two batters I
ever backed were Evan Williams who ended
up doing Twitter and then Kevin Rose and
by the time I met Kevin no venture firm
would hire me nobody thought I knew
consumer Internet because I was an
enterprise software guy nobody thought I
knew how to invest and I was like Kevin
look I just I really need you to take my
money on this thing and I you know
that's what we call a leveraged open
trade I'm afraid that um I'm gonna have
to go on hunger strike in your apartment
if you don't take my money in this dig
deal and you know he ended up letting
letting me you know Kevin and then Jay
Adelson let me invest in Digg and you
know Digg had a kind of circuitous path
but you know I look back on it that was
the sort of the booster rocket yeah and
you know it's funny people talk about
who back to them or whatever you know I
I think it that it was Kevin's
generosity that sort of sort of got me
God sorry no I get caught up with this
stuff sorry about that yeah
so uh so uh so you and I share a similar
affection for the same guy
Kevin's internal yeah yeah also one
goofy [ __ ] you guys know I well
you know more about that stuff I know
more about well it won't get into that
but how do you connect with Kevin I mean
how did that meeting end up happening
well it was a Ron Conway was really
generous so I heard about this guy named
Ron Conway I've reached out to him who I
mean probably still that was thought of
as The Godfather Fame the most famous
angel investor world right and so so we
go to the Oasis and and I was at the
Oasis I care maybe the goose and I say
Ron saying hey no no a restaurant in
Palo Alto in a mental part notice I
think it was the goose and and so so so
Ron's like hey great to meet you and I
said Ron I just want one chance just one
chance to work with you on one thing
just give me one chance it's all I need
and he's like okay whatever you get your
chance what what does that mean and I
said well there's this company that I'm
interested in called Digg and I had to
come up with my own independent
conviction about but there's no way like
how am I gonna ever get in touch with
Kevin Rose right I'm just some random
dude and so Sirhan's like he looks at
his spreadsheet and he's like oh yeah
I'm meeting with him next week and you
want to come with me to see Digg and I'm
like sure let's do it and I just knew
there you know I knew what they were
trying to do you know I cared a lot
about their mission and you know I
wasn't talking about things like cohort
analysis or you know was like what was
the retention and the decay factor of
the users it was more like you guys were
transforming journalism and this is like
super important it's like the wisdom of
the crowds applied to stories and it's
so like it was just I think that part of
why Kevin gave me a shot and j.a was
that they just knew I just cared a lot
about what they're doing for my own
reasons well I think that from from the
opposite side of the hobee's brunch
table when I heard you talking about
startups
you were always genuinely
personally vested and excited about the
products and you spent a lot of time not
just looking at the deal structure and
the this and the that and the
particulars of whatever the projections
might be but the product itself
yeah and knowing Kevin as well as I do
now like I would see that as a key
factor I mean all so many other things
to him than gravitating to you in that
way
and I when I think back to our lunches
we've talked about all these various
things and I would pepper Mike with all
these questions like wait what's what's
a clawback what's pro rata I don't know
what that is what's this what's that and
eventually like any of it matters yeah
it's it's all blindfolded monkeys
throwing darts but I really wanted to
know how the best blindfolded monkeys
threw the darts so we're digging into it
and I remember at the time I was I was
pretty but this was before the 4-hour
workweek popped because keep in mind
that that book had an initial print run
it between 10 and 12 thousand copies
right I mean not even national
distribution no one expected it to do
really much of anything and I was eager
to take a little vacation and I thought
this two-year vacation called an MBA
might be interesting so I was looking at
Stanford Business School and I made all
these visits and there were some great
classes one was taught by Pete Wendell
venture capital inside the trenches
really great class by an operator but
then there's all this theoretical stuff
that I just couldn't quite stomach and
after I don't know four or five of these
lunches I said wait a second maybe I
could put together a real-world MBA and
make this you know Tim Ferriss fund in
principle and spend 120 grand over two
years and learn all these things and
develop those relationships and view the
hundred twenty case some cost like
that's gone it's tuition but I don't
know if you recall but right off the bat
what do I do
so I asked Mike if he'd be willing to
let me piggyback on on a couple of deals
to Co invest and be really sort of cheap
labor not to try to over deliver to
these companies and I you want to
mention that you can I'm not gonna bring
up the name of the company
but there's this company that you you
were very measured and in assessing and
he told me about it and it was super
popular I think in Taiwan or somewhere
and I got so over enthused I was like I
want to put in 50k now keep in mind
that's like a 50k of 60 for my first
year and in the first deal I wanted 250
can I remember what you said to me at
the time in your very Mike way you said
well well Tim uh don't you think that
might be a little aggressive and I was
like no man there's gonna be the next
Google and I decided you're like okay
and then yeah that didn't that didn't
that forced me though if you want to
talk about like life saving you from
what you want losing I mean it wasn't
immediately lost that's part of the
tricky one tricky aspect of the startup
stuff is like you might not have a clean
loss for many many many years yeah you
just might have like you solve that
quickly yeah so you might have been
walking dead scenario or it's just like
I am Legend and you're like oh now what
do I do
kind of like certain areas in SF at six
o'clock anyway so I need more alcohol so
I can excuse all the things that I'm
going to say where was I oh yes
so the point was I had to then figure
out something called advising because I
was already out of money in year one and
that led to in that period of time a lot
of the absolute best connections that I
made including just just to highlight
something that comes up over and over
again and try the mentors it comes up
over and over again in conversations
with you there are these catastrophes or
business failures that really end up in
no uncertain terms sowing the seeds of
really huge leader success right like
you mentioned thus acutest path of dig
but who cares because you befriended and
became an ally of Kevin Rose who knows
everyone just about in tech and is very
generous with making introductions and
if he cares about you and believes and
you he'll make those introductions
similarly I ended up at one point
introduced to Garrett camp and I advised
StumbleUpon StumbleUpon didn't work out
but we had a chance to work together
extensively and then what a Garrett
can't go on to do he started this thing
that people laughed at called uber cab
LLC which then got renamed and became
uber right so that at least on paper has
worked out very well that's more
important than clawbacks
yeah more important than closet so first
and foremost thank you for shepherding
me even as a viewer quick study as much
of a blunt instrument as I was into all
of that but can you tell us about some
of the responses from the venture
capitalists these rejections like what
happened can you tell us about a meet
you'd have to name nails like no how do
those meetings go I don't blame them I
mean I've never made an angel investment
before I was from Austin Texas I had no
network here I just show up saying hey I
think I want to be a VC and you know
that's not a that's not a very
straightforward path and so you know I
would call up Sequoia Capital and say
hey I'd like to interview for a job it's
the koi capital and that's just not how
it really works and so you know I have
no animus towards anybody like they
probably you know they probably made the
right decision at the time for what
their parameters were see you have a
characteristic it seems at least in the
way you express yourself that I don't
see in a lot of people and that is you
seem to hold very very few grudges I
don't think I've ever heard you express
ill-will towards anyone especially in
this day and age that's a rarity is that
something that you've always had by by
birth or is that something you developed
why is that it's a waste of time how did
you learn that how did you embody this
because if you I don't know I kind of I
kind of look at it like life is short
you don't have much time every day is a
gift and the part of the secret of
happiness is to figure out what your
gift is and to offer to the world and to
like not worry about all the noise and
the hype around you that says what you
should do you know think for yourself
and don't waste any ergs and energy on
this stuff that doesn't matter
you and holding a grudge is a symptom of
not knowing how you want to spend the
gift of today and so you know it's hard
it's hard to hold a grudge if you're if
you're so focused on I'm excited about
these things I can do a good job at this
I can't wait to do this stuff how do you
have time for grudges it's just it just
doesn't make sense right it doesn't make
sense
I mean I there's a few people you know
just be honest but when you land in
Silicon Valley
sequoias like and it wasn't just Sequoia
shave I prize shape they're not screwed
dude reason I'm just saying I'm singling
them out because I was taking a fling at
an impossible dream and Sequoia like hey
Harvard I want early acceptance to story
and I want to start in the middle of the
year even though I get on the prereqs I
mean in a sense right and I had no
resume no grades it's a hard pitch and
they're really good at what they do
turns out it was yeah yeah but you land
here you don't get the jobs you are
given this this gift of an introduction
through Ron with really smart
wordsmithing hope you guys are listening
like the pitch is really really
important and nuanced you end up meeting
Kevin Rose so you invest in Evan now at
the time was at Twitter or was it there
was o do it was so walk us through how
that unfolded well I thought you know I
was in Austin and what I would do is you
know my kids were in grade school and so
we weren't sure whether to move yet so I
would come out every Sunday night and
stay on Thursday and it's funny because
when you're on that pattern on the plane
some of the same people are on the plane
like system integrator consultants
people from Deloitte and stuff and I'd
be like oh it's the brother see that's a
but what's what's going on but so I'd be
on these plane flights with all these
people and we would we would go from
Monday to Thursday and this is always
dangerous with the bottle liquid courage
yeah
and so I thought okay I'm gonna I'm
gonna take nine months and figure out if
I can find something exciting a Silicon
Valley
such as basically immigrated here and
the reason that I did that was that I
thought the the web was shifting from an
Internet of connected pages to a
platform that would connect people and
it just felt like it was kind of time to
get the party started again on the
internet you know the bubble had burst
the the meltdown had happened and I saw
things happen I saw Tim O'Reilly talk
about web 2.0 I saw
stuff about podcasting and broad caching
and stuff like that I was like it's just
clear to me this is just obvious that
something major news is happening and I
just have to go to California
I have to go right now not wait another
day and so so I had do that and and have
had the best podcasting company and so I
you know Jeff cuber at Google introduced
me to him he said we just ran him off
because he doesn't want work in a big
company but he's gonna do something
interesting podcasting and and somehow
Evan took my money his first time ever
so now he took your money but but wok is
set by the way that's a pretty good
start and investing that's a fact
William did Kevin Rose it's not bad you
know you can argue that the secret to
venture is to get lucky in your first
five years which i think is a pretty
strong argument I think it's a huge
argument yeah but you you've you've
since then been quite consistent I
should now correct me if I'm wrong but
with Oh do uh-huh there was was there a
point when EV was a very good guy
decided to offer investors the ability
to yeah get their money back yeah so
what happened was um so invest in OTO
I'm like okay great
best podcasting company first angel
investment I've ever made just wired the
money and a week later Apple decides
they're gonna give away podcasting on
iTunes and at the time it's hard to
remember now but 85% of all playback
devices where iPods it's like what are
we gonna be the the one you pay for on
the zoom right like it's like what
business like you don't have a business
there's still people trying oh it's so
so so EV to his credit try it for about
a year to figure out another business
and we couldn't and we'd go brainstorm
and we'd look at each other we're like
yeah it's pretty tough and and uh and
and so one day is some of the investors
were getting pretty disenchanted because
they're like you're just wasting our
money you know there's no business here
and so EV decides to give it back to
everybody and so so I'm like look have
you no you don't owe me anything
venture capital is in the word
adventurer has venture in it and you win
some you lose some right he goes well
this is the kind of the deal I've struck
let's
the bigger investors and be it would
help me a life you just went along with
it and so I said well as long as you let
me invest in your next thing and he goes
well part of this deal is I get to keep
this IP that I've been working on on the
side and we're trying to decide whether
it call it voicemail 2.0 or TW t TR and
it's one of Jack is working on it along
with Noah and we're figuring this out
and I'm like what is I'm like come on
voicemail 2.0 and like why don't you put
the vowels back in because like Twitter
or without the vowel sounds like flicker
and that's derivative and whatever so I
don't think I had anything to do that by
the way but like I was just my gut
reaction so he goes you say what you're
doing and I'm like well then what
happened okay yeah then what happens he
goes 140 characters or less because we
wanted to do cell phones and stuff and
I'm like this is before the iPhone right
so so I'm like okay and then what
happens it's like it's like that's it
that's all it does and I say what's the
road map there is no road map what's the
revenue model there is no revenue model
and so I say math like why do you even
think this is a product much less a
business a company and he goes oh I have
no idea if it is but he goes here's the
way I'm thinking about it like blogger a
million people used blogger software and
this is f first company was blogger he
was one of the pioneers of blogging he
goes podcasting it's kind of hard you
had to use audio studio you had to
record stuff you had to put it on RSS
feed he's like it just took more effort
he's like what happens if you had
microblogs
and rather than a million people did
microblogs 10 million people did
microblogs
he's like I think of 10 million people
did microblog so the burden of proof
will be on the people who are negative
and so I was like sounds good to me I'd
like to invest in Twitter or voicemail
2.0 whatever you call this thing and and
he says well it's you know it's not a
company there is no investment but uh
and then and then a few months later
maybe six months later
Twitter blows up at South by which is
such a delicious irony right because
it's from Austin right the town I just
come from and a couple weeks later F
says hey and I thought by then it's like
a hot-air balloon drifting away there's
no way I'm gonna get to invest you know
I have is gonna forgotten and
everybody's would be chasing him he
calls me up one day and says hey did you
mean it when you said you want to invest
in Twitter and I said yeah and he goes
well we're about to take our first money
and if you want to do that now is the
time Wow
yeah it was a good guy yes so like I I i
remember that because both of those guys
were good to me you know like i just
some random joe schmo guy and both of
them you know gave me a chance to be
involved in their companies and yeah and
the yeah i try to remember that every
time an entrepreneur pitches us I you
know I try to remember the grace those
guys showed me and our stories
intertwine in so many ways because that
I met him right around the time we were
hanging out exact on this book and 2007
South by Southwest I begged and pleaded
with Hugh Forrest who was running South
by interactive or at least the
programming side still is still is and
I'm now a neighbor of mine effectively
and I beg and plead I said if you have
any last minute can I know you don't
have any spots because I've already been
rejected multiple times but if you have
a cancellation there's anything that
moves and there's a spot please let me
know I'd love the opportunity and lo and
behold there was this chance 2007 which
at the time to put it in perspective
Twitter all of the tweets in the world
we're being displayed on these big
screen TVs that were positioned around
the conference all just one feed moving
kind of slowly every Twitter user I was
briefly in the top 100 I was very proud
of that
until Ashton Kutcher came along just
like kicked my head right over and I do
I never cracked the top 100 well you
only really need like 500 one point then
it was gone but I should have been my
cat Twitter but I was like oh come on
like how there's so many people who have
that story they're like oh I just chose
like Hawaii a steak five
I know is my username because who it's
not gonna become anything then again I'm
stuck with that for the rest of my life
here but I ended up getting an email
from Hugh and he's like hey if you meant
it like we have an overflow room that
had a cancellation a sponsor isn't gonna
do their check so if you want to even 45
think you blew up at South by - I did
and it was in what was really funny
about it is I was so nervous so nervous
was my first presentation really about
the book and it was before the book came
out the book came out in April 2007 this
was in March and I was staying at a
friend's place cuz I couldn't I did I
wasn't gonna pay for the hotels they're
all sold out also if you get a room it's
like a thousand dollars a night during
South by so I stayed in my friend's
house and I would go into his garage and
I rehearsed my talk in front of his
three chihuahuas and I'll explain I'll
explain why hey my friend had other
things to do and he had real job so I he
wasn't gonna be there but the chihuahuas
you had to be at least like 10 percent
Tony Robbins to keep them engaged and
these dogs are that your secret no is
that your I could be 10 percent Tony
Robbins I'm doing pretty foreign tribe
of mentors would that would be your like
talk like it's I'd say here's I am I got
Rick my secret trick for networking
first practice with dogs because they
don't care about the content so much but
if you're monotone they just kind of go
and then turn around and walk away so I
was in the garage and I'm like kind of
doing this hand wavy stuff to keep them
engaged this I totally believe oh no I
remember the garage and then I go to the
event and I had all these fancy slides
and everything prepared and what happens
blue screen of death my computer died
and so Mike okay well I guess I'm just
gonna have to do this without any of my
prompts and I did it but I'd rehearsed
so much that I had it in my head and
yeah so Hugh also one of those people
it's like to this day if he ever asks me
like hey could you help us with X Y cos
alpha it's like it's course oh yeah
course I will because you know it's like
that one opportunity and I also want to
emphasize one think he looks a well you
know but the luck was there with Twitter
at the same time it was absolutely lucky
but it's like every year there is
something to draft on I
every month there's something like that
that you can draft them you just have to
look for it but you're gonna but the
other well the other thing is it's kind
of I guess we talk about grudges earlier
to me like the opposite of having a
grudge is like to enjoy seeing somebody
do well right and like with when I was a
founder or you're just trying to do real
company stuff and make the company
happen and you're like okay we're gonna
go on this ride and hopefully it works
out but one of the fun things about
being an investor is you get to see
people do well you know you get to see
you know like Logan and John from lyft
ate beans until they raised their seed
round and when we had our first board
meeting and looks at the financials and
says you guys aren't paying yourselves
minimum wage and that's illegal in
California like we have that it's so so
like and now now people talk about how
much money lyft has and out Carl Icahn
is invested in Google Capital but like
like I remember him when they were
eating beans right and and and it's just
fun to see them do that well yeah it's
fun to see you do this well right I mean
it's like we had no reason to think the
4-hour workweek was gonna be that big a
deal
I mean you hope it will Isis to believe
it wouldn't be a big deal but I mean it
was just like every time I see you know
I'll get a call from somebody who's like
a reporter that says hey would you do a
quote for this article about Tim and
some major publication I'm like wow he's
just killing it that's awesome right
it's just fun to see it's a lot more fun
to spend your energy on deriving joy
from that and seeing your friends do
well especially friends who are like
worthy of doing well and won't be
changed by it like that's a lot more fun
than remembering who wasn't nice along
the way you know yeah that's a drag
I've been working on the grudge piece I
don't have many but yeah I mean like the
Arab Spring or like when I would I'd
pick up Sloan on a play date you know my
daughter Sloan and and the parents of
the play date would say is it true you
invested in Twitter I saw them on Oprah
and then the Arab Spring happened and I
was like wow this company it's kind of
working we got a chance to on this one
so you mentioned your daughter
I want to bring up something that I've
thought a lot about since you mentioned
it to me
and as context for folks what I've
really tried to do in the last at least
five years is to look at the lives of
people I look up to in a holistic way
before modeling them all right so what I
mean by that is it's tempting to look at
say the business success of person X and
then replicate everything they do but
all you may see is one tiny piece of the
puzzle and then in actuality they walk
around in shambles and every other
capacity so I've tried with the
interviews and the books and travel
mentors to really look at things
holistically and I remember asking and I
asked the even though I don't have kids
I asked parenting advice of friends a
lot because I'm curious to see how they
look at it and at one point I asked you
we were on a hike and I asked you what
advice you would give to a new parent or
someone's thinking about becoming a
parent and please correct me if I'm
getting this wrong but my writer
versions could be better but to my
recollection there were two main points
that you made and there could be more
but you said number one really teach
your kids and train them to be optimists
because without that you're lost and
with that you can at least look for see
solutions and silver lining and so forth
and then the second part was remember
that your kids owe you nothing like they
didn't ask to be born you'd show
remember Wow I do remember it was
meaningful to me I really made an
imprint and your job is to give them
love it's not their job to give you love
that's right that I chose to have them
they didn't choose to have me right they
owe me nothing yeah and like I find it
helpful to think about that but but like
the the hope part I think is is
important for them like the the way I
look at it is unfortunately unless we
solve some breakthrough problem we're
all gonna die so you could choose to be
defeatist about that or you can choose
to say the fact that we get to live at
all is just this huge gift
it's so like I think that one of the
things that you can do for your kids is
you can help them feel optimistic and
happy about the fact that they have the
gift to be alive and that don't be
defeatist about this world you had the
gift of today and as long as you have
the gift of today like you should be
like you're you're on the path to the
light right and and if you could if you
can give your kids the gift of being
optimistic and hopeful about the future
and grateful that they have the time
they're gonna have like I think that
that's helpful for them because like
kids get jut that they get judged and
you know all of us are unkind to
ourselves in our own mind and we're
judged by people all the time and it's
easy to just forget that just today's a
gift to be grateful for that gift be
optimistic that tomorrow is gonna be
another day where you have another gift
so when your kids or say one of your
entrepreneurs I mean startups are full
contact sport right I mean yeah people
take their lumps in in major ways and
bad things happen all the time whether
it's with your kids or some of the
founders you've worked with when they're
going through a really rough time what
do you what do you say to them and it
you could give a real you know specific
example or just a general principle then
I'd be curious to hear how you would
think about that well so so like these
founders that we've worked some of them
are just extraordinary right and so I
I'm reluctant to say we had much of an
impact I think the thing that sometimes
I've done that I've been proud of is
like when they're in the depths of
despair you know like entrepreneurships
like this where there's no there's no
even path and there are times where
you're just like everything is against
you and you're just like how did I get
myself into this and this is so terrible
and I think I've been better than most
at those times that kind of saying
you've got this how do you how
and sometimes sometimes they need to
hear that is it just the words or how do
you deliver it like what makes no I tell
I tell him look look you know Twitter we
couldn't keep the servers running we
couldn't decide who the CEO was twitch
it was justin.tv we didn't even know
what twitch was that stirring Chegg was
Craigslist for colleges and then
Facebook decided to compete with us that
we pivoted a textbook Reynolds and we
only had 30 days left of cash and like
ng moco we had 45 days of cash when
pivoted from app downloads of
free-to-play and lyft started out as M
ride and when we launched lyft we
weren't even sure it was legal some like
guys like guys I've seen way crazier
than this you got this and and sometimes
the founder needs to know look
entrepreneurship on so I like I like to
say I like to invest in people I would
enjoy getting in trouble with because it
happens every time and like when you're
in trouble with these people what's it
gonna feel like is it gonna feel like
okay it's us against the world yeah
or is it gonna feel like how did I get
myself involved with these people and so
like I like people where I'm like we're
in the foxhole together screw the rest
of the world what they think we're right
they're wrong let's rock and roll right
and so so that's kind of I think that
we've been like I like to say when I was
an entrepreneur one of the things I
learned is in my early customers they
didn't just buy what I was selling they
bought because they believed what I
believed we were in on a secret together
and like when I work with founders I
like to say I'm in on a secret with it I
believe their secret and like we think
the rest of the world is just wrong we
think we're right and we're gonna prove
it and so when stuff goes wrong we're
like yeah it's just a setback speed bump
whatever but but like in the end it's
like we still believe in our insight
we're right let's let's prove it let's
prove it what about for yourself if if
you can think of you know in the last
decades could be anything but when when
you
could you give us an example of maybe a
tough time that you went through and how
you found your way out of it or what
helped you find the way out of it could
be any any facet of life gosh
there's a fair number you know Liz Liz
and I broke up you know we've been
married for 17 years and things didn't
work out and that just felt like like
like I really failed as a person and I
was about to fail as a dad and you know
like what else what else was there if I
failed at those things and then what
could I even think I was successful at
that was a that was a tough time but but
you know fortunately kiddos turned out
okay and you know it tried the hardest I
could to navigate that time the best I
could and you know kids turned out great
and Liz and I get along just fine and
you know you you win some you lose some
but but at that point in time it just
felt like everything I had done and this
life was screwed up and I just totally
blown it how did you not just succumb to
the depths of despair and stay there
yeah and someday you know we need to
have some more wine to talk about this
because I know you've said that you've
you've struggled right at times with
feeling depressed and I'm like the worst
person to talk to the press people
because I just don't understand the
concept like like it's like I'm not
judging but right now like I'm just like
today's a gift yeah and like I have to
like make the most I can out of it and
if it doesn't work out make the bow
sound tomorrow
and by the way like I don't look at that
like I don't think that my way of
thinking is better than your way of
thinking like it's sort of like your
leaner than I am you could probably run
faster jump higher I don't sit there and
say give me your legs i I just realized
that we're all different and I realize
that that like I've had a few blessings
in life and one of them is to be
grateful for every day and and like to
that for that to be the high-order bit
no matter what's happening I'm like you
got to have today so did that was that
just a life raft that you had throughout
that entire period that each morning
you'd remind yourself of or how did it
manifest on its just leave it just it's
just ever-present it's just ever press
just obvious to me it's like breathing
oxygen and I need to borrow your code
all right but but I don't say that is
like listen to me and my advice I'm so
smart it's just I was lucky enough to be
configured and wired that way so I want
to make a suggestion to everyone in the
audience and this is based on observing
Mike over and over again when someone
says to you well you can explain it to
me I'm just I'm not a fast thinker I'm
from Texas when someone pulls that you
should really be careful and I actually
borrowed that from you and I was like I
think I can use this because most people
think people from Long Island or idiots
great sabe yeah you know explain it to
me ganks I'm not clear my brain doesn't
move that fast I'm from Long Island and
everyone's like what and then so thank
you for allowing me to have to just um
that I could help you act simple okay so
I wanted to bring up and this is
actually something we have not spoken
about publicly or privately before but
commander John Boyd yeah
can you explain who commander John Boyd
is and why you're a fan yeah so
commander John Boyd was a flight
instructor for the Air Force and he
there was this expression that in a
simulated dogfight he could he could
beat any pilot in like 30 seconds or
some outrageously quick amount of time
and people were like well how does he do
that and he taught he taught this form
of combat which it was about moving very
quickly and
so it's if you place yourself in a time
I was reading about John Boyd it was
also when I was working with Eric Ries
and Steve Blank and so Eric Ries was a
consultant at floodgate before he wrote
the Lean Startup he's famous just like I
have this magnetism for famous future to
be authors I guess but but uh so we we
were talking and we're like something
really important is happening here
offshore labor search engine marketing
open source software broadband
penetration global markets and it seems
like you can get a proc to market for
less money you can do it faster and
Steve Blank started talking about this
guy named John Boyd and so John Boyd is
his flight instructor in the Air Force
and he could beat anybody a dogfight
super fast and and Boyd's fundamental
insight was that sometimes you can win a
battle purely by being faster so like
let's say you're in a Russian MIG and
I'm in an f-16 and I make the wrong move
but you haven't moved yet and then I
make the right move before you've moved
yet just the mere fact that I was able
to make a move in course correct before
you made your counter move means two
things I can get in the right position
for relative to you but more importantly
it's very disorienting to you because
you don't know where I am I was here now
I'm there and so the the philosophy of
John Boyd that was inspiring to me back
in 2005 and one of the reasons that
start floodgate was I was like you can
do this as an entrepreneur and investor
and so the f-16 fighter jet was designed
to John Boyd spec an f-16 doesn't fly
faster than a Russian MIG but it changes
directions faster it so the f-16 fighter
was a system it wasn't just the plane
which could change direction faster it
was the mind of the pilot and the mind
of an agile pilot with an agile plane
will be too much repeat a Russian MIG
all day long and so so I was like that's
what's gonna happen with startups and
that's why 500,000 is the new 5 million
and that's why we need to go fund these
agile entrepreneurs because they're
gonna be able to force multiply
and the big competitors who've raised a
bunch of money are going slower and
doing waterfall development they're
going to be disoriented by how fast
these companies move and so like what I
what I really learned from Boyd was kind
of this idea that if you if you are a
speed based competitor you can be wrong
but still be right quicker which makes
you right right which which translates
very directly to Blank and Eric Ries and
that's right Minimum Viable Product and
iterating you could be totally off base
in the beginning which a lot of your
biggest hits have been and right not
ninety three percent of our exit profits
that come from pivots and so you know
you look at that and you say gosh when
we invest should we even care what the
business is I mean it's a legitimate
question so like cruise automation right
that's one of our recent wins you know
Kyle had started twitch we made a bunch
of money on twitch and he starts this
company called cruise it's like a roof
rack that does autopilot self-driving
I'm like Kyle that's a bad idea because
you're gonna lay have 20 customers in
the world there's only 20 car companies
that matter and they have concentrated
buying power and they can design you out
unless you're like ten times better and
there's gonna be competition blah blah
blah so six months later he's like okay
you're right the roof rack idea was dumb
I've got this new idea I'm like what's
your new ideas like I'm gonna make
Nissan Leaf self-driving and I'm like
then what are you gonna do he's like
well you know there's a lot of ways you
can monetize that you can do a fleet of
cars you can sell a cars people you do
something like okay let me get this
straight Kyle now you're just gonna
compete against everybody here you
compete against uber and lyft and Tesla
and GM and everybody Bosch he's like
yeah but you know I'm passionate about
this I've been doing this since MIT is
my research project and I've just I just
think this is the way to go and I sat
there and I thought about it I was like
you know this guy made me 84 times on my
money last time I wrote him a check I
think I'm just gonna write him a check
it's so I so I go to the partner meeting
at floodgate and thank God you don't
have we don't have vote
system and I say I say you know I think
I've decided I'm gonna do this cruise
deal and everybody reads me the riot act
and they're like Mike come on
like I understand that a business model
can be vague but like you cannot even
articulate a path where this is a
business and neither can Kyle and I was
like no but you don't understand and
then he's an awesome founder he's got
incredible insights a very passionate
blah blah so like everybody just is like
talk to the hand this is stupid whatever
so we had two new venture partners who
became partners Ryan and Arjun and six
months later they get bought by GM for
more than a billion dollars and Ryan and
Arjun go boy it's really a shame we
talked you out of this cruise deal and I
said oh we funded cruise we funded it I
secretly have super voting rights on
every deal
no wait floodgate there's no voting
system it's just somebody has to pound
the table it's so if somebody pounds the
table says I will take ownership of this
and I am responsible for the outcome of
our returns the deal happens but if
everybody around the tables and a - and
says I think this is a good deal for you
to do Tim or you to do an or you to do
Ryan or you to do Arjun but nobody says
I will pound the table I'm irrationally
in love with this doesn't happen so like
we you know we kind of think that in
this super early stage kind of love
conquers all and it's like you know when
you're going through all these times
you're getting all this trouble it's
your love for the idea and the founder
that will cause you to like overcome
whatever you face and you have to have
enough authentic love and passion for
the idea and the founders that you're
willing to pound the table and say I
will defend this I will defend 140
characters or less even though people
say it's stupid in 2007 right so just
need you just need one person who is who
in some cases irrationally exuberant and
willing to defend the idea for a go
signal for sure and then so this is this
is really fascinating to me yeah we're
not exactly a private equity shop no but
I'll it strikes me that some of the best
investors I know have a similar or close
cousin approach to that like if they
have somebody who's willing to just put
it all on the line who's already been
vetted because they were hired as a
partner yeah okay kid like it's on you
then but if they're really willing to go
yeah go to go to fight for it and and by
the way like if your partner floodgate
yeah you pound the table but guess what
we keep track of the deals you did and
if you like lose tens of millions of
dollars with no returns it's nothing
personal but like you just don't seem to
be cut out for this
you're not allowed pound our table
anymore it's also like when I pound the
table for a deal I know just as much as
any other partner that I am taking
ownership of pounding the table and
we're going to all help each other and
we're not going to say yeah I told you
so but it's like if I pound the table
I'm saying I care enough about this idea
that I'm willing to have some of my
track record and credibility be tied to
this how do you differentiate if you
look at for instance ninety-three
percent of the returns coming from
companies that pivoted yeah when you are
observing a founder or trying to help
and just by way of getting the most
convoluted question possible question I
get a lot is how do I know when to
persist of my idea how do I know when to
quit or how do I know when to pivot
that's a hard question to answer
yeah but when I spoke with Marc
Andreessen a while back for the podcast
he said you know sometimes people pivot
so often it's like every time I see them
I'm paraphrasing here it's like watching
a rabbit go down a maze it's like yeah
it's like every two days it's a
different couple yeah it's like they
think it's a mulligan not a pivot what
all right so how do you how do you help
guide or even assess a a good pivot
versus someone who's merely unfocused
yeah so um and you know it could be that
I've just been had a string of crazy
beginner's luck and so that is a very
real potential factor yeah but but the
way I see it is that you are right when
went not because people agree with you
you are right or wrong based on whether
your first principles thinking is right
or wrong and so if I see a company where
it's not working but I still believe in
the first principles of the idea I say
this is great we still believe in the
first principles and we know more than
we knew a year ago that's a fundamental
advantage like why would we want not
want to double down on that and so
whereas what what happens too often is
you say this doesn't work it doesn't
have traction we're not gonna be able to
raise money you know forget about it
and the problem with that is that if you
live with the results of other people's
thinking it's it's like if somebody
really smart like if I if you know I
guess if if Reid Hoffman says to me this
is a bad network effects idea because if
it doesn't conform to network theory in
these ways I'm like okay that's data
he's the smartest Network effects guy I
know the best first principles thinker
about network effects I know and I
offered a first principle to him that he
said you're wrong on first principles
I'm like hmm I pray oh listen to that
but like if somebody like with Chegg
right when we did textbook rounds people
said oh people try that before with
varsity books and like who gives a [ __ ]
that was five years ago like five years
ago is it today
and so like like to me it's about like
what are what are just your first
principles reasoning behind why you're
excited about something and are your
first principles reasons being refuted
or doubled down on because to me the
valid definition of a pivot is the first
principles are still true but you
learned something from the data on the
ground that caused you to double down on
a new aspect of that that nobody else
knows gadis you have yeah in spite but
like that may just me be giving a good
explanation for why I got lucky that is
perfectly reasonable point of view for
you to take yeah I mean it's is
certainly possible
I would tend to assess it as certainly a
component of skull but if you're looking
at then let's just say you have the
first principles maybe then you have
strategy then you have tactics and you
have tools you could look at a stack are
the first principles in your investing
experience mostly spotting say
converging trends that people haven't
spotted before what would be an example
of first principles as it applies to at
one of these will you surf
do you serve poorly poorly i surf even
more poorly yeah but but like I like the
metaphor of surfing because you could be
a skilled surfer but you don't really
control surfing right you can sort of
control the board ish even if you're
good you can only barely control it but
you can't control the wave and like I
look at that to me the magic that
animates the tech industry is a
combination of Moore's law and
Metcalfe's law and so I think we all
benefit from the magic of Moore's Law
Metcalfe's law and it's like literally
as powerful as the ocean waves below you
when you surf and so like I look at it
like the job of a start-up founder is to
surf a valid wave and the wave is
usually bigger than the company right
like when we invest in lifts and cruise
we had this belief that network
capitalism is supplanting vertically
integrated corporations and that there
would be network transportation just
like I believe there's gonna be
networked real estate network
manufacturing all this stuff and so we
believe that those gathering waves are
more powerful than any one company and
that the the job of the tech
entrepreneur is to leverage the awesome
massive power of all the you know all
the fury of the ocean beneath them of
Moore's law and Metcalfe's law just surf
into the beach and you know like give
Moore's law enough time it will breach
the advantage of any incumbent and give
Metcalfe's law enough time and it will
create an insurmountable moat Google
tried to take out Twitter with Jai ku
didn't work didn't matter because
Twitter had a network effect and so like
to me like the tech industry is magical
like there's been tulips in the past
there's been the crash of 29 there's
been the real estate bubble there's
bubbles
time there's manias all the time but
tech is animated by two valid
exponential forces that are super
powerful and they're the asymmetric
attack vector of the entrepreneur they
are the they're the rock in David's
slingshot and so I look for founders who
have some type of fundamental contrarian
insight about where a wave is about to
gather and then hopefully they have the
stuff to surf it and if they do I'm like
hey let's rock unconditional love let's
go well you you gave me some related
advice really early on I remember
meeting more by the way anymore why
would ya think I think I have a wine
deficiency yes yeah Leslie I forgot you
thank you you gave me some advice I
remember it was at a restaurant in Palo
Alto there was an event gathering Reed
Hoffman was speaking I was attending and
we were having wine much like rhyming
right now and we were talking about some
deal I was flummoxed by because I had
certain primitive parameters for
investing and I was getting somewhat
ridiculed for my simplistic parameters
like I need to be a power user of the
product I need to it needs to match with
the demographic the sort of core
audience that I have and I got a lot of
flack for it and I Maria said to me well
if those are say you didn't use these
words then but like your first
principles those are your sort of
criteria if if you fought it you're
going to make in some cases really good
investments when people are pooh-poohing
the idea but it perfectly matches so
your criteria when it's when they're
right based on first principles
conversely if it doesn't match your
first principles and you're in getting
into a deal because it's closing
tomorrow but we can feel or whatever if
you're just following some consensus
however small but it doesn't conform to
your first principles that's where you
can lose your game yeah this is where I
like people talk about social proof I
think social proof is [ __ ] I think
that it's so my favorite example is
actually an Elon Musk example so I don't
know if some of you may have heard this
but I thought you can say I think some
of you may have heard of him sorry to
assume yeah
so so he talks about SpaceX and most
people think SpaceX is like a better
NASA but that's not true so you think
about a rocket what point three percent
of the cost of the rocket is the fuel
and the rest of it is what gets burned
up in space what doesn't come back so
Elon says okay if you could have a
reusable rocket you could have you could
maintain ninety-nine point seven percent
of the value of the rocket by bringing
it back to earth and if you could do
that you could have a two orders of
magnitude improvement of the economics
of space travel
that's first principles thinking or when
F says if ten million people write
microblogs that's ten times more the
burden of proof is on people are
negative and so like I don't have to see
the business plan to say that's an
insight I can get behind
right conversely I'll see plenty of
business plans that look incredibly
straightforward and I eliminate them
immediately because they're just not an
exponential enough and they're not first
principles enough and my whole business
isn't about how often I lose it's the
magnitude of the rightness when I win
and so like I when I win I have to win
super freaking big this is a such an
important point and it because it
applies to the light from not just well
it depends like if your PE guy you don't
want any you don't want more than
private equity you don't want to have
more than like a 15% loss ratio sure so
your your you want to take out risk and
you want but I'm not a risk taker outer
I'm a luck multiplier right like I'm not
asking what can go wrong because I'm
investing when it's worth zero right I'm
asking what could go spectacularly right
as a rare event and I only have to be
right a fair number of times as long as
the idea has the exponential awesome
power to just take us to the promised
land well well this is part of what
appealed to me about the startup game as
you explained it to me because it's a
hits driven business you can be wrong a
lot but if you have decent rule
that have some basis in reality maybe
maybe maybe then you as long as you're
this is we don't have to get into like
portfolio theory and stuff but yeah as
long as you're investing enough in these
bets that they can say return the fund
or whatever the parameters might be it's
a it's a fun game and certainly a
dangerous one but let me ask you this
because I remember how impactful and
then we're gonna go to audience Q&A and
my in my my my pink basket that I
brought if you were teaching you can
pick the age it could be college
freshman college senior high school
senior doesn't really matter graduate
school if you were teaching a class on
entrepreneurship so you're not teaching
people how to be investors oh we do now
we're teach once Stanford oh you do well
that makes this easy so yeah what do you
teach where did what are the sort of
differentiators of the class what we
what we try to do is help people
understand that there are things that we
can learn from these prime mover or
entrepreneurs who create massive
abundance and it's about more than just
having a good product product market fit
clearly important but designing the
company what's your culture are you
gonna define it upfront or just kind of
let it happen
what's your category are you going to
design your category just let it happen
are you gonna chase revenue or are you
gonna accumulate attractive customers
and so like what we try to what we try
to emphasize a couple things one is
great businesses truly are valuable and
so we should try to think about building
a scalable business with the truth of
value in mind rather than what's the
latest fad and how do we raise money or
what's a paper unicorn or any of that
stuff but then the other thing that we
we worry about some is that you look at
some of these companies and the problems
they've had with their culture and a lot
of these people come from Stanford or
the top schools and it's like it how do
we have
some impact where if if only one person
who might have gone off the rails is a
founder in that dimension doesn't
because we're like you know culture
matters building company foundation
matters how people treat each other
matters and some of this stuff is like a
blockchain transaction you get it wrong
you can't go backwards or like the
metaphor I like to use like the Hertz
rental car parking lot if you back up
the tires explode and so you can't some
of this stuff you can't really back up
and so getting it right the first time
there's a lot of counterintuitive
lessons and it's more about just having
a good product it's about designing a
company in a category in addition to the
product and you know having a point of
view about how you're gonna bring
abundance to the world and not just get
rich and so the class is sort of about
that and about just like oh the other
idea is that like you don't if you're
prime mover you don't just have to be a
tech entrepreneur like you could be the
French Laundry guy who Keller Thomas you
can be Elvis Presley and you invent rock
and roll or you can be Albert Einstein
you could have a theory or you know MLK
at a dream but it's sort of the idea
that we try to express to people is find
your gift and express it your way and
entrepreneurship is only one way to
express that gift but if they learn
anything from the class it's not be an
entrepreneur like these people if
entrepreneurship happens to be your
calling great here's what great people
do but figure out your calling figure
out your gift you don't have much time
don't live someone else's life don't
live by somebody else's thinking live
your gift and actualize it to the
fullest how do people who say hear that
and I'm sure you go into much more
detail in the class no no 13 lectures
but for those people listening if they
wanted a place to start just to get a
toehold and they say god I want to do
that I just don't know
my gift is what would you say to them
like what are the sort of whispers
through the ether they should pay
attention to or any indicates a spend
time with awesome people and work on
things with them and you'll find it but
most people most people fail to find
their gift not because they can't find
it
it's because they're too busy worrying
about what other people think and like
one of the things that I find so like
one of the things I find inspiring is
that I wrote this post one time and I
was surprised that so I call it finding
billion dollar secrets and the point
that I was trying to make was that
billion dollar secrets are everywhere
it's just that people aren't looking to
pick them up off the ground they're
looking at each other they're looking at
status they're looking at hey when I was
in high school I got rewarded forgiving
the teacher that answered the questions
the way they wanted it and then I went
to the right college and got the right
graduate degree and got the right job at
the right company and lived in the right
neighborhood and had the right designer
kids sent him to the right designer
schools and was in the right country
clubs drive my right designer car and
they get they get focused on you know
Peter Thiel would probably call this
mimetic behavior right this this idea of
people's desires being defined by the
people around them and what's gonna make
a good impression on the people around
them the best entrepreneurs I know
they're just like screw all that I know
why I'm here
in this world that secret on the ground
that's my gift I'm picking it up I'm
doing this and and like that to me
that's the thing I tell my 20 year old
self my 15 year old self my kids is like
figure out your gift your gift it's not
it's not the world's opinion of your
gift it is yours it belongs to you and
figure out the gift that belongs to you
and express your gratitude for the time
you have by offering that gift I love it
ah you guys can see why I've bugged Mike
so much over the years the questions
speaking of questions
sure wow this must be this is like the
Willy Wonka golden ticket of questions
thanks oh look at this oh look at that
rogue question givers alright I hope no
idea lot more from your answers I think
I know this is like the improv jazz of
question receiving all right so I'll
start with the start with the first one
and then we'll just kind of bounce
between these so the god a two-part
question always which by the way means
two questions where would you have moved
besides Austin there are a few places I
looked I looked at I love Austin I've
want to move there since I graduated
from school I just didn't get the job at
trilogy software a funny story founder
of trilogy was my roommate in college I
could have helped ya didn't know what to
do I was I was I was I was lost a babe
in the woods so I bolted Colorado I'm
huge fan of Boulder I also looked at BC
I really liked British Columbia and
areas up in Canada sorry Americans thank
you and there were many different places
that I considered but Austin has this
gravitational pull for me so I ended up
there which changed my mind on the
significance of fiction versus
nonfiction really it was because I had
onset insomnia and I did not want to
turn on my problem-solving apparatus by
reading business books of so long before
bed and I found that fantasy dune
Ender's Game stranger in a strange land
the name of the wind read that but be
prepared to wait like 17 years for the
last in the trilogy you ever read that
kraut Count of Monte Cristo
you don't haven't oh my gosh speaking of
a book about grudges what was so it
didn't since we're on books what what
books do you most recommend or gift to
other people mmm
lately I've liked there's a there's a
woman named Ronnie where call
she wrote a book called the top five
regrets of the dying and she was a
hospice nurse who would spend time with
people in the last 90 days of their life
and she would she would learn like what
their regrets were or sometimes she'd
learned what their happiness was so
there was an example of this woman who
was from a super-rich family and she
decided to marry an artist and the
family excommunicated her and she's like
32 years old she gets cancer she dies
and she hasn't heard from her family in
years and her mom comes to her at the
end it says you know to be honest I was
just jealous you were living life on
your own terms and I've got all these
obligations I don't even like my life
that much and I was just kind of pissed
off that you could go marry some artist
and be this happy and I realized like
how wrong I was
but this woman who's dying says I have
no regrets I got to be with the person I
wanted to be with and like I would have
loved to have live longer but nobody
knows how much time they're gonna have
at least I got to have the time that I
got the way I wanted to happen the best
I knew Val and and then they would have
another person who the opposite was true
they would be dying and they'd say
promised me brawny that you will not
live life according to other people's
thinking because I lived my whole life
trying to please other people and if I
could have it over again I wouldn't do
that
and so she she does a great job of like
having the example of the person who did
it well with no regrets and the person
who's like [ __ ] right I'm dead now and
like I could do it over again I'd do
different and so so and and it's it's
motivating to say gosh you know how am i
measuring up against those five things
and so so I like that book because it
kind of takes people out of the here and
now and kind of forces you to confront a
broader set of issues yeah I think that
for me in the last few years I had a lot
of death friends passed away in the last
two years or so and including Terry
Laughlin
rest in peace who's in this book and
just a few weeks ago and I found it
in an odd way reaffirming to familiarize
myself with death and grief and grieving
in in almost a pre-emptive way I mean
one of my favorite people
I'm sure you've spent time with a Matt
Mullenweg incredible entrepreneur but
first and foremost just a beautiful
human being and he lost his father in a
very unexpected way and he recommended
on grief and grieving to me and I think
it's I think it's a very useful exercise
to familiarize yourself with the details
of death and people passing and I
learned a lot of this from Julie who's
my love of my life and puts up with me
and you know she's helped all these
people who've had cancer and so as a
result she ends up seeing a lot of
people pass and you know I think more
than anybody she taught me that in the
last in the last bit of time you have
all the [ __ ] falls away right all the
expectations all the external stuff and
so you just hope that when that when
that time comes you're like I did the
best I could you know did it the way I
could and so that's uh that's why I find
that that book helpful it's not because
I'm preoccupied with dying I hope I live
a long time
but it's like when the time comes I want
to say I did it my way I did the best I
could I honored the gift that's a good
book
and there's business books too but we'll
do that so much I think that's a good
place to move alright is everybody cool
well if you have to leave you have to
leave at people cool is going a little
longer I'm having fun I hope you guys
alright so here we go this is a left
turn for we're talking about but I'm
curious to hear your answer what
emerging technologies or theoretical
technology that could really go wide
do you believe our most promising for
anti-authoritarian disruption similar to
how it's a leading question similar to
Bitcoin disrupts government control of
money maybe I'm very interested in
crypto and blockchain you mentioned ok
blockchain earlier so I'm gonna too bad
we don't have enough all here yeah but I
would be curious to hear first your
thoughts just general thoughts on crypto
and blockchain and then any other
emerging technologies that you think are
promising for anti-authority disruption
ok so I hope this isn't a shaggy-dog
answer but all the stories are really
long RINs but so so for better or worse
I'm a little bit of a history buff when
it comes to business and so I took this
class when I was in business school an
only Harvard Business School would have
a class called the coming of managerial
capitalism and but it was a fascinating
class besides a name rolls up so like
for example like in the year 1820 there
weren't any companies in America with
more than a hundred employees you know
cuz you had people trading selling
muskets or fur or like if you are a
really big monster company you are like
a spinning loom in Waltham Massachusetts
and and spinning yarn and fabric well
then the railroad and the steam engine
come out and that changes everything so
like what people don't realize about
people like John Rockefeller and JP
Morgan and Andrew Carnegie like imagine
you're doing Standard Oil and you want
to compete with a guy in Pennsylvania on
oil prices
you don't just whip out your cell phone
and call the branch manager and say hey
lower the prices run this
out of business I mean there's no
accounting there's no org charts there's
no salary managers we don't even have
the Telegraph yet we don't have [ __ ]
right and like Rockefeller is building a
company against that backdrop and then
you know JP Morgan's like well there's
nobody who has enough money to own a
Transcontinental Railroad so maybe I
should do this thing where you create
these fractional units of ownership of a
company will call it stock you're you're
some guy who sells your blacksmith in
1820 and somebody says do you want buy
stock in a railroad you're like what
good does that do me stock in some
random company doesn't exist why would I
want that
and so like but what happened was the
modern corporation emerged and it drove
the standard of living of humanity
13-fold from the year 1820 to 2000 the
richest man in America in 1870 was
Cornelius Vanderbilt he didn't have
flushing toilets he didn't have running
water he didn't have electricity you can
have all those three things now and be
defined as poor and so I look at it and
I'm like people say capitalism is
screwed up I'm like what are you talking
about
like I'm like it's a freakin miracle
it's like it in 1800 you had to work one
hour to get six minutes of reading light
today you work one hour you get 300 days
of reading light it's a miracle and and
you know there's a lot of stuff that is
wrong with how people are practicing
capitalism but free trade and voluntary
you know I have this to offer you have
that to offer we get to trade without
somebody interfering that's not the
problem that's not the problem we have
well what I think is happening today
this where blockchain gets in I'm here
in a little Texas sorry for this [ __ ] no
no I believe that that blockchain and
things like it and and Moore's Law
Metcalfe's law are the fundamental
animating forces of what I like to call
networked capitalism and I believe that
some day value is going to be created
by creating a large company we have a
lot of employees that work for you and
produce a lot of stuff but instead it's
gonna be the people who create and
curate software-defined networks and I
think that Tesla is a software network
defined car company and I think that
Apple was a software network defined
phone company nokia thought they sell
widgets Apple thought no we sell sell
software-defined phone the bet between
Tesla and GM has nothing to do with
who's selling more cars
it's that will Tesla figure out
manufacturing faster than GM figures out
how to be a software-defined Network
capitalist company right so so like ok
now back to blockchain there's a there's
a book I like a lot called the wealth of
networks by Yohai benkler I read it
about ten years ago and it influenced my
investing a lot and one of the things
that that benkler talked about was we're
gonna move from the tragedy of the
Commons to the wealth of the Commons and
the examples he used back then he had
dig in the book actually and he had
examples of user-generated content
open-source software well what if just
like the stock market was a new way to
practice capitalism for the moderate
corporation animated by the railroad
steam engine that is a new way to create
abundance because you couldn't have had
a national railroad unless you had a
stock market you couldn't have said hey
who has enough money to build a railroad
there was no one person who did and so
now I believe that crypto has the
opportunity to create the wealth of the
Commons and rather than a centrally
organized equity capital structure you
have a set of people who contribute to a
project on their own volition and if the
other people their peers in the
community judge their value as
compelling they get rewarded so it's
it's kind of like the wealth of the
Commons but like I find it easier to
think about crypto not through the lens
of oh so are you can invest in a crypto
company how many shares are you gonna
own that's wrong that's like asking how
many dollars are am I gonna own in the
Transcontinental Railroad
no stock units are a new thing yeah it's
a different unit crypto tokens are a new
thing they are a new way to create
wealth they are a new way to leverage
the wealth of networks rather than
vertically integrated top-down owned
companies and so like I just believe
that 100 years from now
tokens or something like them will be
one of many ways that a enterprising
capitalist can create abundance in the
world and the more ways we can create
abundance the better does that
obliterate eventual cap venture capital
as we know it or does it just
reconfigure it so that you guys are
investing in the pickaxes yes so like I
don't really it's funny so like I'm
friends with Vinnie lingam the did Civic
and the first time we met he's like hey
I SEOs make you irrelevant but I'm happy
to give you courtesy of my time and I'm
like Vinnie like look I'm just not
afraid of what's gonna be done to me the
question I asked today is what would JP
Morgan do if he's alive JP Morgan
wouldn't be like oh how am I gonna get
disrupted oh gee he'd be like how can I
play offense with crypto and how can I
create new businesses rather than you
know like Elvis didn't say I'm gonna
disrupt jazz right he wanted to create
rock and roll and like when I look about
crypto I'm like what would Elvis think
what would JP Morgan think I think
disruption in tech startups kind of
[ __ ] none of the none of the tech
startups I've invested in had people who
said you know Logan and John didn't say
death to taxis right they were like
ride-sharing is gonna be awesome
it's gonna bring people together and
make things better and disruption
happens after you win almost by accident
and it doesn't happen because you try to
defeat taxis it happens because you
transcend taxis and and like so like
whenever people say I'm gonna disrupt
something I'm like well you're not a
real entrepreneur because
entrepreneurship comes from love and
creation not from anger and disruption
and what am I gonna attack and so like I
don't like I'm not gonna get disrupted
by crypto any more than the next guy
will
so just jamie dimon might by the way I'd
be happy to debate him anytime in
anywhere like this a rumble in the
jungle jamie dimon i can't wait for this
to happen so just so nobody gets fired I
did get the wrap-up smiley face sign but
I'm going to temporarily ignore that
I apologize just so that everybody knows
someone has done their duty and I'm
going to continue for a few more
questions and then we'll wrap up I
appreciate everyone okay with that cool
so I'm having fun with my bud Mike oh my
god all these questions this is the same
person what nascent tech could most
disempowered the state where do you see
tech potential for removing government
control over the individual holy [ __ ] we
got a bunch there's one of the reasons I
like the wealth of networks is that the
wealth of networks potentially creates
the opening to reestablish the idea of
trade as a voluntary activity between
people and the government's role is not
to own everything or legislate
everything or give everybody handouts or
free Scooby Snacks it's - it is to
protect the rights of people that's why
I believe valid role of governments to
protect the rights of people and what
we've allowed our government to do is to
have unsound practices with how they
create how they treat money right so the
Fed is jacking with the money supply and
it's hurting honest people but if we
want to explore that we can but like the
Fed jacking with the money supply is
picking the pockets of the middle class
and it isn't right and and and like the
crypto has the the opportunity to say
money should have a price just like
everything else and just like we need to
separate politics and religion we need
to separate politics and economics
yeah oh my god we'd get out so many
right no no it's great man I can't wait
for this rumble in the jungle Jimmy
diamond it's gonna be great
I want front-row tickets all right what
were the traits you had early on that
made you successful I'll just leave it
at that
that's from Jignesh I'll leave the last
name out just so I don't have to get
permission for keeping you in the
podcast I just think that I was lucky
that I was born with parents who were
just really good to me and inspired me
in ways that were surprising that I
didn't understand at the time like when
I was uh but not when I was in the third
grade my dad bought me this book called
how it works Illustrated for my birthday
it was all these diagrams and how
product you know how it was a dishwasher
workout is it a mother's book it's a
great it's a great book and he writes in
the front he's like I know this is a
little bit advanced for a third grader
but you know it'll make you think
differently about life and you know
someday you're gonna invent things are
gonna be in a book like this what is it
like who has parents like that like I
didn't decide that just like just like
you you're you you know it when your
parent their kids owe you nothing it
doesn't mean you can't be grateful when
you get lucky and have good ones yeah
you're here
yeah I'm curious about that too uh you
know I also I think in a lot of ways one
the parent lottery I wish I could give a
better answer but the one thing my
parents did there are a few things my
parents did that I think we're very
helpful in retrospect now it's all kind
of post hoc analysis right so who knows
but I would say number one I you know I
wasn't it's not like we we did have a
flushing toilet and electricity so it's
not like my parents are yeah you're but
we didn't have for neos Vanderbilt yeah
but we didn't have we didn't have a lot
of extra cash floating around parents
never made more than 50 grand or so a
year combined and anyway the the point
was two things number one is they said
like no you can't have the new bike
can't do it
can't do this but they said this is I
mean maybe it was by a necessity not by
engineering but they said the one thing
we have budget for is books so if you
really want a book like we'll figure it
out and so we used to go to the
remainder table in this bookstore in our
local hometown and pick books and I
remember to this day some of those books
just like you do fishes of the world was
when I want to be become a marine
biologist for 10 plus years because of
this book and bought it for whatever 70
percent off and I carried it with me to
school every day because it's the
playground for me I was a runt I was a
really small kid born premature got the
[ __ ] kicked out of me
like weekly until sixth grade so I would
stay close to the teacher with this book
and I remember I've never talked about
this by where this one teacher
substitute teacher not my real teachers
because they knew me but the substitute
teacher said to my mom you know you
shouldn't have you shouldn't let him
bring that book to school he's gonna
destroy it my mom was like what are you
talking about like I can destroy that
book like it's a most important book yes
and they were very good at training us
to want books so that was a key and then
the second was my parents and my mom
particularly really good at just
exposing me to a lot of stuff and it was
free stuff it's like all right we're
gonna take a trip to the aquarium
and it's free we're going to go to the
beach we're gonna collect black sand
with the magnet and I'll try to explain
what magnetism is and my mom threw so
much against the wall and every once in
a while something would stick and then
she would just put everything behind it
yeah yeah me too like I read some book
and I said well the best example this
dinosaur bones is in the Museum of
Natural History in Washington DC and my
mom would say well we live in Princeton
New Jersey at the time and there's a
Museum of Natural History New York and
Mike but that's not where the biggest
one is and that's where like sure enough
we've been going to Washington DC to see
the biggest guy and like Carolyn maples
like had like if I was interested in
dinosaurs and that's where I wanted to
see the biggest dinosaurs like by golly
we were going to Museum of Natural
History in Washington DC and maybe while
we're at it we'll go to Gettysburg and
learn something about Civil War but it
was a one other thing that I think is
good and then on to the next thing but
my dad also told me don't have heroes
and I think what he meant by that was
that hero worship is a form of not
thinking for yourself because heroes
first of all a lot of times they're kind
of a story and you don't really know
what they're really like and what really
happened and why they decided what they
did but the other thing is defining
yourself relative to somebody else's
accomplishment or how somebody else acts
causes you to not spend the time to
discover how you can be your best self
and so like it's okay to respect the way
somebody thinks or it's okay to respect
a talent that somebody has that you
could learn from but that's different
from saying oh my gosh Bill Gates is
awesome I want to be like Bill Gates
because Bill Gates is awesome right he's
awesome at being Bill Gates but you need
to be awesome at being you and like
having a hero can cause you to drift
away from that so my dad was always very
whenever somebody famous on TV you know
Ronald Reagan was president when I was
young
he'd be like be very careful not to have
heroes you don't know their whole story
he's like he may be a great person but
don't have it don't have that person as
a hero
figure out what you admire that they do
and try to understand that but don't
don't say I want to be like that person
ever it's a good guideline yes pretty
good that's pretty good sir I don't know
how I figure that out this is a question
from anonymous very nice handwriting
what would you put on a billboard could
be I don't know if you answered it in
the books I did yeah he did so let's
let's hear it could be that or it could
be something else but how would you
answer that what would you put on a
billboard that got out to millions or
billions of people like there's two
things one would be integrity is the
only path where you'll never get lost
and that's the one that that I put your
book and then the other one would be
think for yourself always and thinking
for yourself doesn't mean don't listen
but it means be willing to have first
principles and you're right or wrong not
because of how powerful the person is
who challenges you you're right or wrong
based on whether the content of your
ideas and first principles is right or
wrong and you should you should seek out
people to challenge your first
principles like goal because they'll
make you better but you should you know
and that's like ego is about who's right
and truth is about what's right and if
you become an authentic truth seeker in
life to me that's kind of what it means
it's like think for yourself yeah it's
for you I'm the first I'm not gonna
follow that up oh come on yeah I know
everybody wants to know your sign a
record player that says the same thing
over and over again alright so I would
say I'm gonna give a new answer actually
give two so the first would be and this
is advice I got really early on that is
stuck with me for decades now you're the
average of the five people you associate
with most and drew of Dropbox many other
people would give similar advice and I
think it's just so important emotionally
financially psychologically it's very
important that you choose the people you
spend time with it doesn't have to be in
person it can be via podcasting
via hooks they don't have to be alive it
could be been afraid on I've learned so
much from Richard Fineman Ben Franklin
for instance is just two examples and
can I just double down that cuz like and
it doesn't even have to be five people
that will help you succeed in your
career it's like like Julie right I was
talking about earlier one of one of the
companies that we invested in the
founders son was ten years old got a
brain tumor and so he has to be operated
on in San Francisco and Julie calls me
and says when are you gonna get here
like a few days later and I'm Mike sorry
am I supposed I'm in this meeting I'm
like where are you she's like I'm here
at the hospital
Hugo's about to be operated on where are
you and I realized like she never said
hey let's meet at the hospital but like
what I realized from her was that she's
like what else are you doing that's more
important than being here right now like
why did I have to tell you that and she
wasn't being judgmental about it was
just to her was just obvious and so like
part of it is not just five awesome
business people or five fortune 500
whatever it's to me it's more like five
people who in their own way make you
appreciate the gift of life in a more
deep way so that you practice it better
and like where you say wow that person
changed my point of view about how to
use my time how to use your life you
know it's we're gonna wrap up in a
minute folks
I said I would give something new I've
given the you're the average of the five
people you so say with most a lot so
I'll give you yeah another one keep
interrupting which is relatively recent
discovery for me which is if you want to
succeed in any holistic capacity if you
want to love the people you care for
fully and have them feel that you cannot
do it if you merely tolerate yourself
you cannot do it if on some level you
loathe yourself for aspects of yourself
and I spent I mean I've spent decades my
life like barely at best tolerating
myself I had some bad things happened to
me and I as a consequence decided to
just hone myself into an instrument of
competition that was it and I found
validation and purpose in that and being
number one and the any joy I felt was
really from observing other people
experiencing joy it wasn't intrinsic to
me and forgiving yourself we're loving
yourself is not a nice to have it is a
must have even if you're doing it just
for other people and the people you want
to express your love to most fully you
you need to solve that and there are
ways to do it there are ways to do it
that's the good news so I would just say
whether it's a book like Tarr Brock's
radical acceptance terrible title great
book or Kamal's book love love yourself
like your life depends on it yeah call
rava Kant's book also exceptional that
is I think the root cause of so many
things that we can perceive is 30 or 40
or 50 different problems to solve and in
fact they're just one or two things that
happen to you that you need to unpack
and contend with can you double-click on
that for a second because I don't like I
think it's like people will sometimes
say hey you should love yourself and
they will dumb down that that they won't
understand the subtlety like of what you
just said and I think that's important
yes so the this
LT if we were to drill down I would say
that and this is borrowing from someone
actually it's in the conclusion of
trevor mentors it because it's that
important to me
Jim lore our lair who's a performance
coach has worked with a lot of
incredible athletes and he l OE HR
fascinating guy on his book mental
toughness training for sports there you
go
I mean what really changed my life is
sure you're good in high school don't
worry I know I'm getting them I'm
getting the stink-eye
I'll make it up to everybody know the
whole story Tim so so you know Jim
expressed to me when I met with him to
learn how to play tennis for the first
time just in the last year which I'd
always want to do my whole life he said
in effect you know the most important
voice we ever hear in our lives is the
voice that no one else hears it's the
voice in our own heads and for my entire
life or I mean really my entire life
it's been the most merciless brutal
coach you would never wish on your worst
yeah like raise your hand if you said
something to yourself negative in your
own mind today yeah right and you can
create even if externally you have all
of the material trappings or rewards of
a financially successful career if you
have the nuclear family that everyone
has dreamed of and painted at Norman
Rockwell paintings if that inner voice
is just a demon on your back you will
not find the piece that you want and
nothing you buy nothing you achieve will
provide that there are just things you
need to unpack so that voice becomes a
different voice it is it fair Tim to say
that part of love is like you can love
your country without thinking it's
perfect and you can love your kids
without thinking they're perfect and
part of like loving yourself is like
saying that doesn't mean I'm perfect
I'm not going to be jingoistic about
myself
it's more about I'm gonna hold myself
and higher enough for guard that I'm
gonna do the best I can with the day
that I have and I'm gonna forgive myself
when I screw up honestly yeah that
that's a big part of it and also for
people who are looking for maybe a
tactical recommendation one thing I
found very helpful and I don't want to
take too much time to go into it but
something called meta m ET ta meditation
or loving-kindness meditation I went
through meditation retreat recently
which is very difficult for me and I was
practicing this just google it you'll
find plenty to convey in my meditation
love and wishes for happiness to many
different people who had helped me
throughout my life and I remember one of
the teachers that this retreat said at
the very end I was about to walk out the
door and she said wait a second have you
done any loving-kindness to earlier
versions of yourself who experienced a
lot of pain who maybe felt unsafe and I
was like it didn't even occur to me to
do that I would encourage everybody here
to accept Laura that and I know where
we're running out of time so Mike I have
one more question and then I'll have
some closing thoughts this is the
tradition and form to ask what is your
60 second idea to change the world
pressure okay think for yourself
and be kind to yourself in your own mind
because 90% of the unkindness that
happens in the world is actually people
being unkind to themselves and if you're
gonna be if you set out to make the
world better or being kind to yourself
in your own mind is probably the most
straightforward high-return
you see your time possible cheers to
that
so Mike I just want to say that it's
been such a joy and a privilege to know
you for as long as I have and I really
hope to spend more time with you I mean
we've spent a lot of time together but
I'd like to spend more time and I really
truly believe and part of the reason I
wanted to bring you out on stage tonight
know you're one of the most genuine
unentitled positive people who want to
also impart the gift of positivity to
the world I've ever met so I just want
to thank you for that all right well
it's been fun to see you do so well well
heaps you amantha ladies and gentlemen
Mike Mable all right thanks
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email for me would
you enjoy getting a short email for me
every Friday if that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favourite
new albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out
just go to 4-hour workweek com that's
4-hour workweek comm all spelled out and
just drop in your email and you'll get
the very next one and if you sign up I
hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
wordpress.com I love with this I have
used it for so many years it's my go-to
platform for blogging and creating
websites I use wordpress.com for
everything everyday my site Tim not blog
is built on it the websites for books
including tools of Titan ease tribe of
mentors it's all in WordPress comm and
the founder Matt Mullenweg when my close
friends has appeared on this show many
times
just search Matt Mullenweg tequila
fairness or quite an exciting time
whether you're looking to create a
personal blog business site of both you
can make a really big impact right out
of the box when you build on
wordpress.com and you'll be in good
company it's used by the New Yorker
jay-z Beyonce 5:38 TechCrunch Ted CNN in
time just to name a handful
and one of my friends at Google children
nameless has told me that wordpress.com
offers the four best out-of-the-box
SEO imaginable on foot it's one of the
many reasons that nearly 30 percent of
the Internet is run on WordPress you do
not need experience or to hire something
that's perhaps the best part where fresh
calm guide you through the entire
experience they have hundreds of designs
and templates that you can use and it's
easy to get started there's no need to
worry about security upgrades posting
any of that therefore 24/7 support and
they're very very responsible leave
questions they can write back to you and
this allows you to create the highest
quality with the least amount of
headache and friction so if you're
building a website for Korea my friends
come to me and ask what I use what I
recommend to use the answer is
wordpress.com so check it out you want
to get started today and learn more with
a 15% discount off any new plan go to
wordpress.com forward slash Tim create
your website and find the plans right
for you to learn more take a look
wordpress.com 4/10 50% off a brand new
let's check it out
this episode is brought to you by
convertkit my go-to email service
provider I use them for everything if
you've ever wondered to have
professional bloggers podcasters
youtubers and so on can build a platform
they control and get the word out about
their best content email is still the
answer link it's all social social
social but one algorithm change oops
bait and switch and I only reach ten
percent of your audience that is why
I've doubled and tripled down on the
mill after reviewing many different
email service providers I ended up
selecting convertkit before you know
like 500 Friday which goes out to about
a million people now because convertkit
delivers on what matters most to me at
least easy view systems split testing
and resending technology both very very
important high rates of deliverability
and great hands on customer service so
whether you run a business or simply
have say a serious blog convertkit has
integrations with more than 70 different
services just that anything you might
need including hosting sites like
WordPress e-commerce platforms like
Shopify lead capture technology like
bounce exchange or sumo and many more
they also offer a visual automation
builder that makes it really easy to
deliver the right content to the right
people in your audience just when they
want it if you want to segment in
different ways there's a lot of people
do it convert kit offers plans that
adjust to the size of your business so
it's a good option whether you have a
thousand people or 1 million on your
list and certainly I am planning on
growing
and growing and growing and I don't like
switching email service providers so I
thought very carefully about this before
it's like you know check it out
take a look at convertkit dot-com fold /
Tim that's converting CEO and the ERT
kitv.com for life Tim and you can get
your first month for free kick the tires
test it out that way give it a shot
make sure that works for you your
business and all of that goodness if
you're like me I hope you'll find that
they get the job done that's certainly
been my experience let's check it out
again that's convertkit comm forward
slash Tim for a free month of email
services
you